[Music]
congratulations on the newsroom I love
the show
I have nothing I'm so yet I really enjoy
it and I cannot believe you I have not
think about your your career you've done
so much great work you've not once been
nominated for an Oscar and that's a
little unbelievable to me I know
everyone here we're all horrified on
your behalf
yeah yeah not not no I haven't won
haven't been nominated haven't even been
haven't presented but it's hard to win
if you haven't been nominated
well that's true that's true maybe
that's but though I did I did actually I
have won an award
I heard squid in the whale it's a movie
I did long I love squid in the whales
and I did what they what you do you
campaign you know like MIT or Obama you
just get out there from from for five
straight months I talked to everything
above a high school paper right and
depending on the high school I'd even
consider that but but I mean you could
do to get the Erinyes I hoard myself in
a way that an actor is never done and
then got to the morning of the Oscar nom
nothing and then two days later I got a
call that I had indeed won an award from
the AARP or the best actor over 50 you
brought the award yes this is real I
said you know I didn't even know the
Golden Barcalounger
[Applause]
it does look like something we would
make up but we didn't that is the video
I had to fly to LA to receive it and the
great Shelley Berman and Angela Lansbury
presented it was very solemn occasion
some people weeping ya know it's a big
damn deal and I used it to use it to
hold my meds I may borrow some later now
I'm just curious when when you're not
acting which obviously you've very
accomplished in that field music is a
passion of yours and you perform you
play music you perform it I do III I've
been playing about 30 years and I go
into clubs and you know just play and
and and people you know the last thing
an actor that should be doing is singing
in front of people we just don't want to
see that you know guys trailblazers like
William Shatner kind of wrecked it for
for all of us I love Bill never met him
but I love him
but you feel that yeah an actor you
should stick to what you're doing you
shouldn't be branching out day in your
lame station as I was I was told once
you need to stay in your lane and fare
Shatner doesn't really sing he does talk
over music but he doesn't exactly the
same I think he'd tell you otherwise out
of what he does he's very proud of it I
don't know but it's it's a the thing is
I'll go out and play a club no band just
me and a guitar and I'll go out there
and you can see the art and they've paid
money and they've paid to see me they
paid to see one of the guys who was in
Dumb and Dumber they they they to see
you after about ten minutes they realize
they have seen me past tense so now
there's like 90 minutes of oh my god
he's going to sing you actually hear
them say that sometimes you can see
their faces drop and they just do that
and then and then that's when I usually
go in to kumbaya
slow the evening down just to make them
pay it's like it's like a
passive-aggressive anger I'm gonna slow
this down even more
yeah so that you all suffer yeah yeah no
but it's great fun I really enjoy